this video is sponsored by brilliant dog
[Music]
this is the start of a mini-series about
linear algebra the study of vectors and
matrices I'm making these videos for two
reasons
the first is that linear algebra is the
language of quantum mechanics and so
without some of this background I
couldn't eventually teach you some
topics in my quantum series like quantum
computing for example the second is this
topic is so geometrical and beautiful
and yet the way sometimes taught in
university in high school students don't
seem to take away a lot of intuition
about it I'm hoping these videos might
show you linear algebra from a slightly
different perspective than you might
have seen before this is the perspective
that made it first click for me so I
hope it might work for some of you too
and if not don't worry at the end of the
video I'll point you to some other
resources that I really like that could
help instead anyway let's start with
vectors we'll see later that lots of
different things count as vectors but
for now we're going to think of them
very concretely vectors are arrows with
some fixed direction and some length I'm
gonna tell you a way of thinking of
vectors that sounds really silly but I
found very helpful at the Sun let's
think of them as arrows that tell you
where to go a vector says if you start
here you need to go this much in this
direction basically if you put the dull
side of the vector where you start you
end up on the pointy side thinking of
vectors this way makes it really easy to
add vectors when you're introduced to
them you might think if a vector is
three units long and another vector is
two units long if you add them you get
something that's 5 units long but that's
not necessarily true and you can see why
if you think of them this way when you
add two vectors what you're really
saying is if I go the direction the
first vector told me to and then from
that endpoint go the direction the
second vector wanted me to go in total
how far did I get from the start and in
what direction
so in this example the vector
representing the overall path is this
and so this is the sum of these two
vectors by the way notice if you'd
followed this vector first and then this
one you'd still end up in the same spot
so the order doesn't matter at all when
you're adding vectors but something that
does matter is the direction you can't
rotate these vectors around when you add
them to see if you understand all of
this so far here's a quick question
imagine you add these two vectors what's
the sum of them here are your options
and pause the video to think about it
and when you're ready you can vote for
your answer in the poll in the corner
here okay so to answer this you need to
move the vector over here but if you put
the vector this way then you'd be
following this vector in the opposite
direction then what it wants you to go
instead you need the vector like this
and then you end up almost back the way
you came but not quite so this is your
resulting vector anyway now that we
understand how to add two vectors we
understand how to add as many as we like
just keep following directions
good but adding together isn't all the
vectors can do they can also get
multiplied by a number and there's a
simple way to think of this - this just
stretches or squeezes the length of the
vector without changing the direction
for what happens when you multiply it by
negative one for example it just flips
the vector in the opposite direction and
negative 1/3 for example that just flips
its direction then squishes it by 1/3
before we move on to the really
interesting stuff a quick word about
notation I'll write a general vector
like this with a little arrow on top
this is fairly common notation but
there's lots of different ways people
use in fact in quantum mechanics we use
a notation that you've already seen if
you watch my videos and it's like this
anyway say you have some vectors now you
know you can add them together and you
can also multiply each by a number that
squishes it or stretches it but the most
general thing that you can do is both
multiply each of the vectors by
something and then add them together
this is called a linear combination of
vectors and it's the most general way
that you can make a new vector from a
bunch of ones that you already have now
a question you might be asking yourself
is exactly which other vectors can I
make from a given set of vectors for
example if I gave you these two vectors
can you end up with any other vector on
the plane by taking a linear combination
how about see if you can make this
vector on a piece of paper draw
something like this now it doesn't have
to be exactly the same and then see if
by stretching and squeezing and flipping
the original vectors and then adding
them together you can make this third
vector I think the best way to
understand BEC does is actually play
around with them so seriously pause the
video pick up a scrap of paper and try
it and if you think you know how to do
it try it with another example as well
assuming that you gave that a go here's
how to do it for any example draw a grid
like this with your two vectors this
says you need to go
two of these lengths to get here and
minus 1.5 to get here so in my case the
new vector is minus 1.5 V 1 plus 2 V 2
using this method you can take a linear
combination of two vectors to get any
other vector on the plane well not quite
there's one special case imagine if I'd
given you two vectors that are on the
same line one of them is just a multiple
of the other so when you do a linear
combination of them you're really just
getting a multiple of one of
the other one is redundant if we look at
all the vectors that you can make from
these vectors which is called the span
of these vectors it's just anything on
this line but let's see what happens
when we think of the 3d case
how many vectors do you need so that a
linear combination of them will get you
every possible vector in 3d space
clearly two vectors is not enough any
two vectors only gets you vectors on the
plane that they span so you need a third
vector but what if the third vector was
on that same plane then clearly it's
also redundant think of it this way you
can write the third vector as a
combination of the other two so when you
have a linear combination of all three
vectors you can just rewrite it as a
linear combination of just the two
vectors instead and so the third vector
didn't get you anywhere on the other
hand if your third vector is not in the
plane you can get a vector anywhere in
3d you can convince yourself of that by
using a similar grid argument to the 2d
case now if you've understood everything
so far you've understood one of the most
important ideas in linear algebra and
that's the idea of a basis we saw in our
examples that a line can be spanned by
just one vector a plane can be spanned
by two and 3d space can be spanned by
three vectors but only if you don't have
any redundancies imagine that you have
vectors V 1 to V n spanning some space a
vectors say VI is redundant if when you
take that vector out you still get the
same space that happens when that vector
can be written as a linear combination
of the other vectors in the set as long
as none of the vectors are dependent on
the other vectors like this then we have
the minimum number of vectors to span
that space if you delete it any you'd
get a smaller space then this set of
vectors is called a basis for the space
obviously for any space of vectors there
are many different choices of bases for
example both of these bases work for the
plane and so it's not unique but there
are two reasons why they're still very
important firstly for any vector space
the number of basis elements is fixed
it's called the dimension of the space
the second is if you pick a basis and
you write another vector in that space
as a linear combination of these basis
elements there's only one correct way to
do it
ie you couldn't write that V is also
equal to this other linear combination
it's not hard to prove these two
statements and I think it's really good
practice for you to try so I'd like you
to have a go at it and write your
solutions in the comments now finally I
want to explain the link between what
I've said so far and what you might have
seen about vectors before you might have
seen vectors written as a column of
numbers like this I think a lot of
students misunderstand what this means a
vector isn't really a column of numbers
this is a shorthand what it means is
that there's some basis that you have
for your vectors already fixed then this
vector is a time's the first basis
vector plus B times the second basis
vector etc it's a shorthand for writing
out this whole sum and it's very
convenient but I really hope that if I
taught you nothing else a vector is not
a stack of numbers they're arrows with
directions and you can only write them
as a column of numbers once you've
established what the basis is
before you go I encourage you to try the
following two multiple-choice questions
I strongly believe that linear algebra
is just one of those topics
you can't understand without getting
your hand study even if you thought
everything in this video was very
straightforward there's lots of tricky
questions that can help you understand
the subtleties here are two that on the
surface seem really simple and the
calculation would only take you a minute
but you need to think a bit carefully so
here are the questions and you can find
both of them in the description as well
the first question is about redundancy
the question is one of these three
vectors is redundant which one is it
once you've had a thing
put your answers in the poll here the
second question is about which of these
vector spaces contains the others again
you can put your answers in the poll in
the corner here I'd be really interested
to see what you guys thought as you may
have noticed these two questions are
from brilliant org who are sponsoring
this series brilliant have a course in
linear algebra which I think will
complement this series perfectly because
they introduce the subject from a
different angle by looking at systems of
linear equations I've never seen that
approach done as well as their website
does it and I think the reason it works
so well is because they don't just tell
you the concepts they ask you questions
which make you engage with the material
if you watch my channel you know that I
said homework at the end of my videos
for the exact same reason you can't
learn without thinking about the
material on your own the questions are
brilliant are at a perfect level to keep
you on your toes and do illustrate the
concepts in a very tangible way despite
the fact that I do research in a field
that is basically applied linear algebra
I got a lot from going through this
course so I can personally recommend
I really wanted all of you to have the
chance to do the part of their linear
algebra course relevant to this video so
they've kindly made that free for the
next two weeks if you like their stuff
you can get a 20% off their annual
membership by following the link in the
description and on the screen my next
video will be up here soon where we'll
learn about matrices meanwhile I really
recommend a video series by three blue
one brown on linear algebra especially
if you'd like to go deeper in this topic